office Christmas party is directed by
Josh Gordon and will spec the directors
of the switch and blades of glory and
this is about an office Christmas party
if you didn't know already especially
since that title is pretty much all you
need to know there's not really much of
a point in setting up this story but
essentially TJ Miller runs a very big
company in which people like Olivia Munn
and Jason Bateman work for him Jennifer
Aniston is his sister and she's the CEO
of this company and she swoops in there
and wants to shut everything down and
fire everybody unless this company can
make one last deal to save themselves so
they decide to throw a giant epic
Christmas party and invite the head of
another company they're trying to
partner with to hopefully get him to
like their company and have a whole
bunch of fun in the process
I had no anticipation for office
Christmas party I think it's one of the
dumbest titles of the year it's just the
most basic title they could have had
it's like calling The Empire Strikes
Back farmer boy versus father I don't
know where I'm going with us to my
surprise I found myself having a lot of
fun with this movie and a lot of that is
due to a few comedic performances in
particular that of TJ Miller who I found
hilarious in this film as the head of
this company who's really trying to save
it he's trying so hard to save it and he
just wants everyone to be happy
and make all of his employees feel safe
and protected but he has no idea how to
go about doing that
kate mckinnon who I thought was really
often on this year in ghostbusters got a
lot of laughs in this movie as a super
politically correct employee who wants
everyone to do everything perfectly
without offending anyone and it was fun
to see her character loosen up quite a
bit throughout the film and I thought
she did a great job also not to be
overlooked it's Courtney B Vance who
plays the head of the company they're
trying to partner with he really went
for it in this movie this actor is 56
years old according to his IMDB and some
of the stuff he does in this film I
thought he was great Jennifer Aniston
also had a lot of funny moments as a
super Ice Queen I mean she is horrible
to everyone her family the people around
her it doesn't matter young children she
takes no from anyone and she was
really good in the movie this is not a
great movie I would even hesitate to say
it's a good movie I would say this is a
perfectly fine disposable film
that you can maybe watch at a Christmas
party or just with your friends if
you're in the mood for a Christmas or
winter themed film this is a perfectly
excusable disposable piece of fluff and
that's really the best it has to offer
and if you go into this movie expecting
anything else why it's called office
Christmas party it's pretty obvious what
you're going to get for me the biggest
issues I had with this movie were a few
comedic performances Jillian Bell as
this pimp just really got on my nerves
I liked her in goosebumps but in this
film I don't know I don't know what she
was doing she was just super annoying
and I wanted her character to just go
away for the majority of the time she
was on the screen and that's my honest
opinion on that Jason Bateman is Jason
Bateman he really impressed me in the
gift I think he's a very talented actor
with a lot of range but in this film
he's definitely in his wheelhouse Olivia
Munn is also fine and enjoyable even
though they're kind of the two main
characters they didn't have that much to
work with unfortunately but I did enjoy
their performances overall because as I
said this is just a disposable piece of
fluff that if you go to it expecting
anything else you're going to be let
down also the film gets really
fantastical towards the end where Olivia
Munn is like hacking electricity and I'm
just like I really don't buy this at all
but you know it's just one of those like
throw inhibitions to the wind type
things where it's Christmas anything can
happen and you're like ah mmm whatever
guys in the end office Christmas party
is a movie that has a few really good
laps has some fun performances it's a
perfectly fine disposable holiday film
that most people will probably forget
I'm not seeing this becoming a holiday
classic there's nothing really special
about it to differentiate itself from
other things but in the end if you're in
the mood for a random holiday comedy and
it's on Netflix I don't think it's going
to do anybody any harm I'm gonna give
office Christmas party of b- so speaking
of the holidays I received this in my PO
Box from a very cool fan and I'm about
to open this right now I am kind of
excited and also touched that something
would be sent to me in a very cool
gift bag like this oh
moonrise kingdom criterion collection
thank you so much for sending this to me
I don't have that that's really awesome
where we got here hi Chris I hope you
did not own moonrise kingdom yet I did
not I am looking forward to other Wes
Anderson movie reviews I loved your book
by the way keep up the good work
Andreea I won't say your last name in
case you don't want me to your number
one Italian fan well thank you so much
Andrea or Andrea however you pronounce
your name I really appreciate this I did
not have Moonrise Kingdom on criterion
collection thank you very much for that
gift I really appreciate that guys thank
you so much as always for watching this
review I greatly appreciate it you are
the best and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]